for our wild money moves of the week you
know this is one of our favorite
segments my favorite each every episode
oh boy we covered some some wild stuff
and this story is pretty wild
david uh you like going to strip clubs
ever i've actually never been to one
stop it stop it adam we can stop the
broadcast right now i've never been to
one how's that possible i don't know i
guess my day my generation it's a lot of
porn online
i don't need uh
it's like
why do i need it in real life when i can
get it virtually it's what am i gonna
give you money to show me your all right
one website you know who likes going to
strip clubs and is very willing to give
their give some people that money is it
you no no don't save that money dog i've
been to some strip clubs
anyway pull this one up you know who
likes it the actress the beautiful
actress
gabrielle
the wife of
the legendary miami heat hall of fame
baller
d wade
one of my top three favorite players
ever by the way d wade yeah what he's
done from miami 100 but gabrielle union
she is a connoisseur oh of shrimp clubs
really yeah didn't see that coming she
was like such a genuinely like pure oh
it's always the good girls oh it's
always the good girls that you say oh
she's so sweet oh yeah oh
what's she doing her spare time anyway
gabrielle union yeah
has spent a wtf what the
amount
at strip club and she was on jimmy
kimmel recently okay okay she revealed
this she revealed this you know i get it
and when it comes to strip club she's
like bring it on bring it on that's a
play on words because she was in the
movie bring it on anyway
she says jimmy kimmel asked her you go
to you go to strip clubs and she goes
yeah i've been a few times well
what's a few times how often do you go
how often you go she goes oh 10 to 15
times a year
what what's up she's going monthly
she's she's sleeping bi-monthly she's
just going she's a regular this is
pre-pandemic she knows what's going on
flip-flops gabby what's up baby how are
we doing
welcome back she calls herself a
connoisseur she says sometimes she'll go
with d wade sometimes she'll just go
with her friends or sometimes no she'll
roll solo okay she has a freckle emoji
hold on hold on you got a problem hold
on she's gotta okay if dwayne wade went
on jimmy kimmel he's like dude i go
[ __ ] a [ __ ] ton of times a month
sometimes i go with gabrielle sometimes
i know my friend sometimes i go alone
yeah be a different story you got some
serious problem here but wayne way it's
kind of a scumbag yeah but gabrielle
union goes it's cute it's so cute it's
cute wow she's like she's so quirky
listen if you're gonna be something a
connoisseur of something dude
don't be a connoisseur of strip clubs no
gabrielle be a connoisseur of of reading
of
of investing
okay
of of saving of something that that
gives you an roi don't be a connoisseur
of making it rain
okay
she's possibly listened to fat joes and
little wayne's i might get right i'll
make it around i'll make it rain on him
a little too often a little too much he
took that way too hard yeah way too hard
some people actually do like some people
here i'll make a maker it's like cool
cool song some people are like that is
my anthem that is my soundtrack
saturday night bumped up i'm making rain
fat joe lil wayne let's go make it rain
at the trip club cause i'll make it rain
baby i'll make it i'll make it red i'll
make it rain on these
anyway
jimmy kimmel asked her hey gab
uh what's the most amount you've ever
dropped at a strip club in one evening
you know what her answer was hold on
let's take a guess yes
i say i'm going to do something stupid i
don't know
10k yeah
no you're she said between 10 and 20 000
is how much she spent it one night
keep in mind she's a connoisseur she's
there often ten to twenty thousand and
she says you know it's like one of those
things you don't really think about it
because you got all the booze and you
want to just make it rain and you want
to make sure that all the ladies go home
with a little something something
what what is this a charity it is now
your job
to pay all these ladies rent gabby
gabrielle
feeding ducks at a park what are you
doing breadcrumbs everywhere she's
making it rain my god woman and here's
something i thought of i got to become a
stripper she says she goes somewhere
between 10 and 20 000. hold on what
somewhere between 10 and 11 000 i get
somewhere between five and six thousand
i get oh yeah some between 10 and 12.
that's what you're saying somewhere
between 10 and 20. oh my gosh what's the
gap on how do you not know how that
you're spending 20 grand between 10 and
20 grand i don't care how wealthy you
are i know people worth hundreds of
millions of dollars they [ __ ] know if
they spent between 10 or 20 thousand
this is okay we're watching a t-pain in
the making
let's hope not
i got a lot of heat about dude hey man
you really went hard on t-pain yeah well
you know what he was in love with the
stripper and he lost all his money yeah
okay you want to sing that song buddy
yeah cause i was right last week what's
the song i'm in love
yeah i was ready yeah you were she's in
love with the stripper anyway if you
don't know the difference between 10 and
20 grand you go to strip club you need
to reassess
what you're doing you need to do
some math okay and i'm not saying that
like someone who's worth that amount of
money shouldn't spend that amount of
money that's like you spending 100 bucks
or even a thousand bucks at a strip club
but no if you're spending ten or twenty
thousand it's a little aggressive yeah
how do you gabby
she has to know so look just you said
you've never been to a strip club never
been okay i live downtown miami i live
in australia i live here two blocks from
my house is gonna be a big shout out
right here to anybody that's ever
ventured to miami
there's quite possibly the greatest
strip club slash nightclub ever it's
called 11. it's in downtown miami
you've heard
of course i've ever heard about it yeah
it's basically a nightclub in a strip
club and it's two blocks from my house
downtown miami it's a great time
you
as many women are there as men
meaning people go there three four in
the morning yeah it's open all night
it's a crazy time like when i say women
go like girls like friends like because
it's like kind of like a club it just
happens to be like naked girls running
around there anyway you know i have one
rule when i go there what is it uh
because you can they don't even have
atms you go and you give your card they
just give you cash like from a from like
a teller oh my god i take
i give a hundred dollars
right i'll usually have a hundred dollar
bill or fifty dollar bill on me whatever
because i like carry cash
i'll take 100 singles please that is my
number a hundred dollars good man that's
for me
all right couple drinks here's a tip all
right make it rain four bucks
but so that's my number okay some people
might say dude how do you spend 100
bucks some people might say [ __ ]
cheapskate only 100 bucks but that's my
number okay i have a number when you
have a game plan going in and how much
you're going to have a limit have a
limit 100 bucks is fine for me and
obviously if i want to buy a drink at
the bar i'll use my card or whatever but
have a limit
by the way at this club 11
there's
the the entire floor is covered with
singles everywhere
like recession
not in the club yes there's people that
are like okay yep or why don't you just
uh recycle it throw it back yeah well
there's some people do that
like you know how like you go there's
janitors and they're sweeping stuff up
yeah at 11 there's janitors sweeping up
money straight up this is what's going
on there anyway
this is the future democracy this is the
future democrats
um have a game plan you know i asked
phil heath seven time mr olympia phil
heath yeah said you go to strip clubs
ever he goes yeah i'll go i go well what
do you go for and with his confidence he
goes he goes yeah yeah i should be
dancing for these women they should be
paying me
[ __ ] greatest bodybuilder of all time
you should pay me but he says i go and i
go with buddies
and all i do
all i do
is i get the nastiest
you know fattest whatever
grossest stripper
i pay her no at the dance for my friend
to my friend sitting there boom
big girl rolls up how you doing uh you
want a lap dance no i'm good it's
already been paid yeah you're getting it
buddy phil he's having the time of his
life anyway that's something you could
do but your point is have a game plan
showing up maybe spending 10 to 20 000
drunk making it rain because you want to
pay for these ladies rent not a good
game plan gabby get it together have you
know and here's my last point with this
what else can that 10 or 20 000 do
what kind of roi could you actually have
with that money right
yeah okay oh yeah yeah maybe that's a
trip for you your family maybe that's a
down payment on something maybe you're
putting on the bitcoin maybe you're
putting that into crypto so for you at
home you might be thinking dude 10 20
quid i mean i don't have that i'm not
drowning a ship club but maybe for you
that's 500 bucks maybe for you that's a
thousand bucks and you're going out on
saturday night what else
rather than bottles and strippers could
that money have been used for
just what else
right
like
i say this all the time i can afford a
rolex okay i can afford a five ten
twenty thousand dollar rolex i really
can
no rolex i don't i don't know how to use
an apple watch i could i have another
watch but now come on because i've taken
that money and i put it into a roth ira
yeah or i've maxed out my 401k
or i put it into an index fund thank you
or i bought in bitcoin with it yeah uh
and i'm constantly thinking is this
money
better used elsewhere and yes you need
to treat yourself and if there's
something you really want go get that
but anytime you're making it rain 10
grand 20 grand or you're buying luxuries
cars clothes jewelry what else could
that be used for yeah so for you gabby
great you had a good time great story
jimmy kimmel
save that money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke